Oh
as we continue to see our world the
utterly transformed by accelerating
technologies extending our capacities to
exercise our will in the world one of
the questions that keeps coming up is so
what is the future of sex right if you
think of communication technologies as
expressing a desire for
intersubjectivity a desire for telepathy
a desire to become one through an act of
communication as consummation right to
share subjectivities with one another
this is expressed by technology this is
connected again to the idea of sex to
lose yourself and find yourself when
this all be the ego in the hands of
somebody else the orgasm is the ultimate
little death but also resurrection right
to become more than whole related to
literally have all of your desires
abolished by the plenitude of their
satisfaction as Roe and Bart's Reisz
about so what is the future virtual
reality environments that stimulate all
your nerve endings and your sex sort of
sex sensors in your body you know
agra fee that arrests your capacity to
lose yourself in fantasy but maybe plot
and and execution akin to an art film
maybe we'll create settings that are
romantic so it looks like not just the
sex act but the sex context that will be
packaged and sold to us and you know
manufactured dreamscapes that are better
than any movie you've ever watched
better than anyone romantic comedy
you've ever seen to lose yourself in
Breakfast at Tiffany's for this to be
the future of sex the future of sex is
real virtuality virtual realities in
which we can lose ourselves in which our
wildest dreams and desires can be
expressed in a kaleidoscopic ecstasy a
multicolored frenzy of orgasms and mind
Gazans and man it's going to transform
sexuality in ways we cannot be bad
rubbing our bodies up against each other
either the desire for the sublime is
going to be clearly seen has a faint
memory right back in the days when we
had to do that and I think what's next
will go way beyond amplifying
[Music]
[Applause]
amplifying our capacity to satiate
[Music]
you